all right joe biden finally scheduled to
hold a
solo news conference on thursday waiting
the longest to do so of any president in
the modern era
now before thursday's presser i have a
few questions of my own for the ever so
weak and frail and
cognitively struggling joe biden um
joe have you will you take a cognitive
test
and beyond biden's cognitive struggles
other many other questions he needs to
answer
for example mr president uh can you
guarantee that every migrant
that comes across the border illegally
will be tested for covet
will you not now realize the mistake of
your border policies
and maybe reinstitute the state of
mexico policy
maybe end the idiocy of catch and
release you know the same standards by
the way that apply to the rest of us
shouldn't they apply to illegal
immigrants i don't see you complaining
about their lack of social distancing
inside those overcrowded facilities we
were showing earlier in the show
will you please let us see the cargo
shipping containers
that allegedly have butterflies on the
windows do you really believe that your
policies and rhetoric
encourage migrants to storm the southern
border many migrants on camera are
saying
yeah you encouraged all this here with
reaction laura trump is with us
um the fact that he had nothing on his
schedule
saturday sunday monday and one event
today
tells me i'm guessing just conjecture on
my part
that joe's likely practicing laura trump
because he needs practice before
any uh big moment
yeah well it's sort of reminiscent of
the campaign sean remember he sort of
hid out in his basement remember we
didn't see for him for a long time
during the campaign he went weeks at
certain points without ever coming out
of
his house in delaware so this is no
different we sort of thought maybe
we would get a little more transparency
from joe biden should he ever get to
this point well we haven't
you just said it this is the first time
in over a hundred years that
it has taken this long for a president
to do a press conference
and gosh i i sure hope that the
mainstream media is ready i sure hope
they ask him questions about the
southern border i'd like to ask him
maybe i don't know
does he think any of his policies so far
have benefited
the american people because so far we've
seen the energy jobs leave america we've
seen the auto plants
are now going back to mexico when under
donald trump they actually came here to
america
he got people back to work in america he
got things back up and running
joe biden is turning it all around does
he think it was positive that he has
affected
at least a generation of young women
with this equality act with
you know taking away opportunities that
they might have
via women's sports scholarships et
cetera their future
but i suspect sean that what we're going
to hear from the media when they
question joe biden
is something more along the lines of you
know what flavor milkshake had he gotten
that day so we'll see
yeah i'm expecting what do you find
enchanting about the office a
question asked to barack obama
vladimir putin clearly seemed to take
shots at joe's struggling cognitive
abilities
the chinese were lecturing our
delegation and our secretary of state
in alaska on the issue of human rights
do you believe that the things that i
see
joe being weak and frail and struggling
cognitively
are enemies see and that they are taking
liberties that they wouldn't take
if your father-in-law were still
president
well i'm sure that's playing a big
factor and absolutely they see a much
weaker person and joe biden being
president of the united states than they
ever did
in donald trump look donald trump when
he drew a line in the sand he meant it
and they
knew it they knew not to test him they
knew not to push him
or push the boundaries with donald trump
with joe biden
it's pretty clear they could probably do
whatever they want
and there's really nothing that joe
biden is going to do
he hasn't stood up to anyone so far he
has a complete disaster on the southern
border
um he's making us look like a bunch of
fools as americans
and we want strength it's peace through
strength that was always donald trump's
motto and it worked guess what we did
not
enter one unnecessary war one new war
under donald trump's tenure
as president of the united states he
actually brought the troops back home
and we were out of the endless wars
under joe biden
i see i think they see exactly what
you're saying he's weak he is frail
and he's somebody that can be pushed
around it's really scary to be an
american right now
it's embarrassing quick question exit
question
still considering a run for senate north
carolina your home state
always your exit question sean yes i i
am still considering it absolutely
all right laura trump thank you for
being with us